before we go any further i have to let
you all know that my channel is
sponsored by keeps which means i will
have an ad from them somewhere in the
middle of this video hello lovely people
i'm alana welcome to my channel where
we're doing another q a today i actually
decided that i'm going to start
splitting q and a's in half
we'll do two a month from now on one
every second week one of them will be
about personal questions or unrelated
questions the other half will be about
gaming of course this is my personal
channel it's a grab bag of whatever i
feel like making it is not meant to be a
gaming channel
but i do get both kinds of questions and
i thought i would separate them because
people are interested in different
things and then i also feel like the
headlines make more sense um in any case
just based on the questions i've been
getting i feel like this one is going to
be a lot about game development i do
have to say thank you to everybody who
has given us
me and the rest of the studio not that i
feel like i can speak on behalf of them
so many kind words for god of war
ragnarok thank you it has been
absolutely so cool to watch reactions uh
i did do a stream on twitch
uh this will be two days ago when this
publishes where i watched a bunch of
people reacting to the trailer it was
really cool to see
i think i might do that again actually
i'll probably edit it into a highlights
video and put it up here as well because
it was just so much fun but uh yeah i
have a lot of questions related to that
and of course if you're new here you
probably don't know there are a lot of
questions that relate to uh working at
santa monica studio game development in
general that i just won't answer that is
the nature of working in tripoli game
development i don't want to spoil
anything i am overly cautious i'm not
the right person to come to
for leaks
hopefully nobody's the right person to
go to fully cause that would suck i
appreciate you trying i gotta respect it
you're excited
that means a lot um so let's get to the
first question here createpunk said how
do you feel about all the outrage
regarding thor and how he's depicted
in god of war ragnarok i think thor
looks cool as hell i think he looks so
badass and uh raph who
i believe i hope i'm not um taking
credit away from anyone else who works
under raffle with raph i believe did a
lot of work on his concept and raph is
so talented um artists man the stuff
they do you know just so freaking cool
so my stance is that i think he looks
awesome how i feel about people on the
internet reacting to it everybody's
entitled to their opinions you're you're
absolutely entitled to not like the way
that he looks but it also from my
perspective is a very small group of
people majority of the feedback uh that
i've seen across the board for ragnarok
has been extremely positive and excited
and i feel like we probably spend a
little bit too much time paying
attention to and signal boosting the
people who are so angry that they're
negative because there's a difference
between i don't like this and like basic
criticism and people being infuriated
and i've seen both sides of that uh to
some extent but i do feel like we spend
too much time quote tweeting and screen
shotting and sharing
the people who uh we feel are toxic and
it's a strange choice across the board
what if we just ignore them and just
kind of silently let their tweets die
you know but i mean yeah the basic
answer to this question is um
it's interesting to read different
perspectives on it it's it's interesting
to see what people think and how people
feel about different things and i'm not
in the slightest bothered
down your rocker uh scott or trailer
reaction can you explain your response
to the trailer being a player versus
being a part of the dev team how do
those feelings blend
um
yeah so obviously i had a very visceral
uh reaction to watching
the godawa ragnarok trailer and i didn't
expect it i think i said this in the
reaction video but
i expected to feel very proud of the
team that's what i expected going into
watching the trailer knowing how
difficult certain parts of it were
having made friends of course with
a lot of people in the studio who've
been working on this stuff for years who
i know how hard certain things were i
expected to
feel proud of everybody else and very
honored to get to work with so many
incredible people who were just at the
top of their field which is definitely
the coolest thing about working at a
place like santa monica studio but what
ended up happening and why i got very
emotional
was that uh
i felt like i was watching people i know
and it kind of dawned on me for the
first time
that
i know
these characters so intimately
i look at them and i go this is why you
are this way here's where you came from
here's how you feel here's how you
express
and here's why and and it is my
life
to know that i think watching the
trailer and and seeing them
be themselves
um and realizing how close i am to them
and and them feeling like friends and
family
you know i think about these characters
all day every day
they are effectively my life
um i just didn't expect and then you
have the realization of
just being
very honored and proud to get to do what
i do for a living is really what it was
is just
oh man i'm looking at these characters
in a way that i've never looked at video
game characters before you know i've
been playing games since i was four
years old we think it's been my entire
life uh it's certainly not the first
trailer that i've cried at i just
i really [ __ ] love video games man
and i really always have
and um
realizing the journey that i've come on
from crying because i was excited about
a video game which has happened more
than once
to
looking at video game characters as
family was just um was just new for me
and
definitely a very different experience
hard to explain why other than saying
yeah they feel like family friends my
life
my hearted soul
living and breathing um in a playstation
showcase so it was very very cool and
really
took me
off guard i just didn't expect
any of that it is time to talk about
keeps keeps is a subscription service
that focuses on making it easier and
more affordable for men to treat their
male patent boldness online with online
doctor consultations with a real doctor
automated shipping and delivery to your
home constant access to your doctor
through online doctor messaging and by
offering generic options of the fda
approved medications for hair loss did
you know that two out of three guys will
experience some form of male pattern
baldness by the time they're 35 and the
best way to prevent hair loss is to do
something about it while you still have
hair left with keeps a licensed doctor
will review your information online and
recommend the right hair loss treatment
plan for you then as we said your
treatment is shipped directly to your
door every three months it's that easy
and my favorite part really is that with
keeps you can message your keeps doctor
24 7 with any questions or concerns you
may have along the way and track your
progress with keepsa's progress tracking
tool no more awkward doctor visits and
all of your questions answered so if
you're ready to take action and prevent
hair loss go to keeps.com alanapierce or
click the link in the description to
receive 50 off your first order that's
k-e-e-p-s
dot com
lot alana pierce now back to the video
charles m said as a video game writer
does knowing what's going to happen take
away any of the joy of playing the game
or is it a whole new experience to be
behind the scenes
so i would think in most cases of video
game development
a lot of people are either constantly
seeing the game or are constantly
playing the game
so
when the game comes out and i play the
final release of it i'm sure it'll be
very cool but yeah it will be completely
different i don't think it will take
away the enjoyment
but it will be a series of oh here's how
this looks here's how this is supposed
to look here's where this went here's
how this happened here's how this
happened just a checklist because it
becomes your job you know it will be a
completely different product it is not a
product that i can consume as a consumer
it will be a um me looking at something
that has a million moving pieces and
seeing where the pieces are in place and
i would think that's probably the
reality for anyone who works in gamedev
but you know i'll play it when it's out
i'm sure i'll stream it and um we'll try
to talk about some of that because i
don't actually know how it's gonna feel
ninja pyro said when can you share your
involvement with the new god of war be
interesting to hear what parts you
played a part in it um probably not
unless it's out in theory i could speak
more to that but i don't want to um
and even when it's out i want to be very
careful to respect
the studio and
how they want to market things
because i am aware that even though um i
have no larger input than anybody else
on the team if not a lesser input again
i haven't even been there for a year yet
almost that by virtue of just having
a following people can take the things
you say
very seriously and turn it into a news
headline it makes the twitter rounds you
know all that stuff it becomes press
so where a dev who streams who has
smaller following can be a bit more
candid i run the risk of um
creating a narrative and i don't want to
do that i don't want to take any
interviews or or
anything away from the team and how they
want to handle it so i think it's a bit
smarter for me if um
while i will be able to talk about it at
some point i try to restrict that so
that i don't become a mouthpiece where
that may not be in line with how the
studio wants to handle something or or
um you know they want to set a certain
spokesperson up to talk about a certain
thing i don't want to just become that
and take that away from people who are
much more deserving of of controlling
the narrative so it's a it's an
interesting line to uh balance but
i'm pretty well media trained at this
point i think we'll be okay
backfandango x asks what role on a game
development team is not at all like you
thought it was before joining a game
development team i think i've learned a
lot about qa actually um how it's
structured how those jobs work how
difficult it is it's always spoken about
like it's this entry-level position that
you can just kind of walk in and now you
do qa and while that does apply
yeah there are people who are
qa experts who are extremely good at qa
who are the leads of qa departments
i think i knew it as this like you know
the people who fixed the bugs but it's
so much more complicated than that st
timmy said hey alana my wife and i have
been loving your content thank you my
question is about the video game writing
process are folks assigned a certain
aspect story character setting or is
everyone riding on mass with so many
writers on a given project who has the
final say
um this would depend on the studio i
think how they approach these things and
i have written on
a number of video games and they all
handle things very differently
but um
the lead writer and the director would
generally have the
final say uh though i would say in my
experience santa monica studio is very
collaborative the slayer23456 said after
being at santa monica studio for a while
what's been the biggest challenge in
adapting to the type of work that you
didn't expect this one's tough to answer
i actually feel like all of the jobs
that i've had before really have led me
perfectly to
what i'm doing now so i don't feel like
there were that many unexpected
challenges um you know i don't feel like
i was thrown in the deep end or anything
truthfully it's probably scheduling
it's probably organizing uh uh the time
for higher-ups to have time to meet with
you is probably the toughest part will
sullivan said do you have one of those
fancy stylized portraits on the santa
monica portrait wall yet
i don't but i do love them i'm sure
it'll happen soon i'm sure the artist
will reach out to me sometime soon very
excited about that casual games
production said have you guys finished
the storyline forgotten ragnarok yet how
much bigger is the game compared to its
previous installment
did you think i was gonna answer
this i mean
you're going to give it a shot shoot
your shot man
but did you think i was going to answer
this question come on callum andrew
asked with the release of gameplay
trailer for god of war 2 what's the
overall feeling been like in the studio
since it's now came out in your feelings
as well as a fan of the series
i would say everybody's been really
excited um it's been so cool to see so
many of the people on the dev team
sharing all the shirts
and getting a lot of love for that and
and watching the reactions um yeah from
everyone that i've spoken to it seems
extremely positive stupid java said
where do you see yourself do in santa
monica studio in the future ps been a
fan since your heavy rain walkthrough
wow that's a long time ago um
i'm not concerned about climbing up any
kind of corporate ladder
i just want to write that is what i have
always loved doing and what i've always
wanted to do
um my goal at the studio is to learn
as much as i can and to be helpful not
to assert anything and that really is it
my goal is to learn and that's the step
that i'm thinking of now i'm not
thinking of um
my future career or
anything like that i just want to absorb
the knowledge and uh
i
feel like i'm in a very wonderful
position to
have the privilege to be able to do that
with so many talented people around me
and i think that covers
the questions
regarding i guess i can answer this one
eli shulem said how did you become a
game designer slash writer
um i have been a writer my whole life
even since i was a kid uh i feel like it
was something that i was destined to do
like almost prodigy levels of writer
um
i was in the top one percent of writers
in my entire country
well maybe it was state
i don't remember what the report cards
actually say um from when i was you know
from when i was an actual
child when i was very very young and
then i went to high school and i was in
advanced writing classes and i went to
writer's camps and again was generally
top of the class i took a grade above
for uh english
i kept writing in my spare time all the
time
and then i went and studied her writing
degree at university and then i got a
job as a writer i was working freelance
at the start and um
just you know kept writing so my answer
to how did i become a game designer
writer um i guess aspects of my job are
actually very heavily game designed in a
way that i didn't expect which is very
cool you do have to think about more
than just the words that you put on a
page but i was basically by writing my
entire life and also being a game of my
entire life so already being in the
industry and having a reputation in the
industry and knowing people in the
industry
certainly helps for anyone who wants to
work in the games industry but really it
almost feels like it was unlikely to me
that i would do anything else this is
what i was always
trying to work towards
um i started to do game jams to get
extra experience writing on games under
stressful circumstances and to work with
different people and collaborative
processes i um asked people at studios i
know if i could sit in their writers
rooms to see how they did things
so that i just basically like
did everything i possibly could to end
up where i am today and luck of course
that plays a part in it right place
right time uh junior positions at aaa
studios is so hard to come by so i got
very lucky that around the time where i
had actually just finished uh doing a
little bit of writing on
a title that is a known ip that i have
not announced
was
just before um
santa monica studio were looking for a
junior writer which is exactly the kind
of position that i am qualified to fill
you know studied at university writer
for 10 years but they're like if you
don't have triple a experience you can't
work in triple a unless you're a junior
um the fact that i had
already been working on you know short
stories and screenplays and all that
stuff which is what i submitted but i do
maintain lucky or not i don't think i
ever would have given up and that is it
for me today everybody thank you all
again um and i do want to be clear this
is a one-off generally i don't answer
any questions about santa monica studio
um it just felt fitting to do one right
now to cover these in the way that i can
but i don't want anyone to think this is
any kind of trend and uh yeah there'll
be two q and a's every month from now on
this one will be the gaming one for this
month even though i do i guess talk
about a lot of personal stuff the next
one will be the personal one where we
talk about anything else movies tv books
whatever the heck else you want moving
travel whatever because i just thought
yeah we'd split them into two so that'll
be in a couple of weeks you can ask
questions for either of them below i
will source them either way and thank
you for watching i will see you guys
next time bye